Jerry when I spoke to you last time uh
for Picard you were I believe filming
the season three finale
um yeah which was a while ago
um is it nice to finally be so close to
actually being able to talk about things
it's really fun although it's a little
difficult because people
years ago that I couldn't remember
anything about the city but it's asking
me about because they wrapped it so long
ago so some of this was you know a year
and a half ago
um
but yeah it's it's it's nice to
um finally get to talk about things like
this guy being part of the show Todd
stashwick who's brilliant beyond words
and I cannot wait for everybody to see
him in action
um and to meet Captain Shaw and oh just
so good so good and Ed speleers being
able to talk about him being with us I
mean this is just we've got such a great
show for season three and it's really
exciting I'm excited for people to see
it I've seen the first six episodes of
season three and I will agree with
everything you said it's fantastic what
can you tease people about the season
without getting in trouble without
getting me in trouble okay we're saying
we're not getting anything I will say
I mean this is not really a verb there's
a big episode
when you're like
just slip about it then it just gets
screeching
yeah um I will say the fans
are going to be thrilled I really
believe that I think that every part of
this story is just
um so beautifully done for all of these
characters the arcs for all of these
characters I think is so respectfully
and beautifully done
um
and when it finishes I think the fans
are going to be very very satisfied yeah
I will say that I can't tease much
without giving stuff away what do you
think what about this
um oh wow uh I I think it it feels old
and new uh it has
and it has something for kind of every
part of Trek fandom like there is there
is nods to the original series there's
nods to TNG and the Voyager and DS9 and
Picard itself it is it is its own animal
because it is it is while it's looking
back it is making something new but with
the ingredients of of the past it's it's
uh and amateur I'm a I'm an old truck
fan myself and I would be
like feel fortunate that this is made
with such hard and affection yeah for
for track uh lovers yeah as well now I
agree there's a lot of nods in the first
six episodes uh that people are going to
enjoy but I have to ask for both of you
of the 10 episodes in season three uh
did you have do you have a favorite of
the 10 and why oh a favorite episode
audited yeah I love for for Shaw I love
304.
personally uh because uh that was the
one upside I got to do everything in
like just without conveying anything way
there's this amazing scene that they
wrote for me with uh Patrick and Ed uh
and then by the end you and I have all
that fun in the engine room and uh like
and it and it ends with such Wonder like
the whole episode ends with this
beautiful so it it sort of runs the
gamut for me in terms of uh what I got
to do as an actor and then as a Star
Trek fan
well it's just a lot of fun I'm
wonderful and heartfelt and all between
I don't know if I can pick one episode I
I
for Seven's Arc I love where we end the
season I love her struggle for this
entire season I love her
discomfort with where she is and trying
to figure out if this is where she
belongs and if she really truly should
be here in Starfleet and I love where we
end up with her at the end of the season
um
that's pretty cool
I will not pressure any more than that
and just say Hey listen I really can't
wait to see the rest of the episodes and
congrats on the first six thanks so much